[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
RYAN BOYD: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd, and I'm a
developer advocate at Google
on our cloud data services
such as Google Big Query.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And, hi.
I'm Michael Manoochehri.
I'm a developer programs
engineer working with the
BigQuery product.
RYAN BOYD: And today, we're
going to talk about best
practices for querying
massive data sets.
This is a video that's
particular to the querying
aspect of BigQuery.
We have other videos that talk
about BigQuery as an overview,
and how the API works, and
how to get your data into
BigQuery, but today we're going
to really concentrate on
querying BigQuery.
If you have any questions after
watching this video,
feel free to reach out to
us on Stack Overflow.
There's a google-bigquery tag
there on Stack Overflow, and
ask your questions, and
we'll be happy to jump
in and answer them.
We also have our Google+
profiles, as well as our
Twitter handles on this slide
if you have any followup
questions that you want to ask
to us individually, maybe, to
clarify what one of us said
during the episode here today.
All right.
Before diving into some example
queries with BigQuery,
I want to actually show you the
way that BigQuery works,
the way that BigQuery processes
its queries.
So let's jump over to
this slide here.
And this is basically the
BigQuery processing tree.
This is how BigQuery queries
are processed.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about how this is
different between BigQuery and a
typical relational database.
So a typical relational
database, you load your data
in, and the relational
database makes an
index of that data.
And then any time that you're
performing simple queries that
are easy to select from that
index, a relational database
is fairly quick.
But if you're trying to do
really aggregate queries over
those large data sets, the
indexes oftentimes
won't find a match.
The aggregates aren't stored
in the index, especially if
they're more complicated
aggregates or over a
sub-selection of the data,
so it needs to do
a full table scan.
And a relational database doing
a full table scan is
sort of like the heart
attack for the DBA.
DBAs hate the idea of full table
scans, because they're
really, really slow when doing
it on a relational database
that's typically hosted
on a single server.
There's only so much I/O
bandwidth for that server, and
so you have really
bad performance.
And BigQuery is actually the
absolute opposite of this.
We embrace the concept of full
table scans and allow you to
query over terabytes of
data in just seconds.
So we're going to show you some
of those big queries here
soon, but first I want
to really give you an
understanding of what happens
underneath the covers when
BigQuery processes
its queries, for
those geeks out there.
If you don't care to know about
some of this stuff, you
don't have to.
That's the awesomeness
of BigQuery
being a web API service.
It's really easy to use
without knowing this.
But knowing some of this helps
your geek inner heart, but
also it makes it a little bit
easier to understand how you
can optimize your queries.
So this is the tree structure.
Again, very similar to like
a relational database.
And in this tree structure, we
basically have the storage at
the bottom, and each leaf node
in this tree is basically
assigned to deal with a very
small subset of your data from
that distributed storage.
So think about something on the
order of tens of megabytes
of data that each leaf node
is reading off of that
distributed storage.
Now, the distributed storage
is distributed, as its name
implies, so it basically has a
lot of different disks, a lot
of I/O bandwidth.
So each leaf code can
simultaneously, in parallel,
read off this distributed
storage really quickly.
And they're loading in the data
that they are tasked with
dealing with.
So think about the leaf on
the left is dealing with
essentially rows 1 through 10,
and then the next leaf over is
dealing with rows 11 through
20, or something like that.
So each can independently
process its own a chunk of
data and do the aggregate
queries on its
own chunk of data.
So you think about something
like a count query, so the
first leaf would count
the relevant rows.
The second leaf would count its
relevant rows, and then
basically it does this partial
reduction as it moves up the
tree where the mixer above it
would add those two counts,
would sum those two counts
together, and that keeps on
going up the tree until you
get the final result.
Now, one thing that I really
should emphasize here--
actually two things-- is one,
our reading from the disk with
BigQuery is only reading the
columns that you're accessing.
This reduces the cost to us to
run the queries, and thus
reduces the cost to you.
And this is all because of the
column or data storage, so we
only need to read the set of
data that's in the columns
that we're touching.
The second thing I should note
is that this is really
different from like a MapReduce
based system which
people often try--
frustratingly--
to compare to BigQuery, and one
of the big ways that it's
different is that we are only
reading from disk at the very
beginning of this
processing tree.
We're not actually reading and
writing from disk constantly
throughout this operation,
which is what a typical
MapReduce operation will do.
MapReduce, in between the map,
shuffle, and reduce steps will
often write and read a lot of
data from disk, and disks are
the slowest point in
this whole tree.
And also, with a typical
MapReduce operation, you're
going to be performing multiple
map steps, multiple
reduce steps, and that
just gets really
heavy on those disks.
Whereas with BigQuery, it's able
to take advantage of the
super fast network bandwidth
that BigQuery has to offer.
All right.
So that's kind of covering the
true geek side of BigQuery,
but now let's show
this in action.
Let's show what happens when you
run a query and see some
queries over very
large data sets.
So the first table that I'm
going to query over here is
basically all of the page view
data from Wikipedia for a
particular month.
So what each of the rows in this
table represents is an
hour-by-hour look at all of the
Wikipedia page views that
happen in that hour, grouped
by the title.
So in this case here, we
actually have the Wikimedia
projects, so this actually
includes stuff other than
Wikipedia, but all the Wikimedia
project, and the
language of the page, and then
the title of the page and how
many views it had, as well as
some bites transferred data.
And as Michael we would say,
there's a long tail here.
There's an extreme long tail.
There's a lot of pages that are
just viewed once an hour
or things like that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: But all
together, this table size,
it's a terabyte per month, and
we're looking at something
like 650 million rows
for an entire month.
RYAN BOYD: Actually, I
think that row count
is off here a second.
We have a bug in our UI.
This is actually 13
billion rows.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Oh, 13 billion.
My mistake.
RYAN BOYD: And we can actually
show you here--
I'll do a very quick
count star query.
So these are the page views in
Wikipedia for July 2010.
And it's 13.5 billion rows
that are in this table.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
For a single month.
RYAN BOYD: For a single
month, and it's over
a terabyte of data.
So let's show the type
of query that we're
going to run on this.
And the query that we have for
you to run on this is actually
kind of an interesting query,
and it's really showing the
power of BigQuery.
I'm showing a couple
different ways.
First of all here, the
simple aggregates.
Michael's going to be talking
about some of the other
aggregates here shortly, but the
simple aggregate of a sum
is a very common operation,
especially with log files and
things like that.
And then we're basically
getting
the top viewed titles--
top viewed pages,
essentially--
from Wikipedia, and
we're getting the
100 top viewed pages.
But we're restricting the set
down a little bit, and we're
restricting the set with this
regular expression.
Now, think about on a relational
database trying to
perform a regular expression
on 13 and 1/2 billion rows.
If you guys want to try that out
there and give me how long
your relational database takes
on doing a regular expression
on 13 billion rows when
it's unindexed.
These are ad hoc regular
expressions.
I can change this
however I want.
Try running that, and give us
a shout out on Google+, and
let us know how long it took.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Imagine
the horror of building an
index on something you don't
know yet with the regular
expression itself.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
You could probably, in some
relational databases, build an
index on a regular expression,
but you wouldn't be able to
change the regular expression
then, so it would take a long
time to build up that index each
time if you wanted to do
different types of analyses.
And that's what BigQuery is
really good at, this ad hoc
iterative analysis.
So in here, we're basically
doing a regular expression on
those 13 and 1/2 billion rows
and finding all the pages that
start with a capital G, and with
lowercase e, and have two
o's in between.
So, think about a page that
looks something like Google.
We're finding the top
100 of those pages.
So this is kind of
our inner query.
We also actually do something in
our outer query to do more
regular expression magic, and
that is kind of formatting the
titles of these pages.
So if you notice when you visit
Wikipedia, the actual
URL has underscores in place of
all the spaces in the URL.
We want to strip those out to
make this very easy for us to
view, so we're showing how we're
doing a sub-select in
this query as well.
So I'm going to hit Run Query,
and I will note that this
query takes a little bit longer
than the typical query
in BigQuery because it
is going over such a
massive data set.
Typically if you're querying
hundreds of millions to a few
billion rows, you're getting
responses in like 7 to 10
seconds here.
But in this case, we're actually
querying over this 13
and 1/2 billion rows and over
a terabyte of data.
So it finished in
22.9 seconds.
And actually, I got rid of that
here, but 22.9 seconds,
505 gigabytes of data
that it processed.
And the reason that's different
than the one
terabyte of data number that
we saw earlier is we're
actually only accessing
particular columns.
Remember we mentioned
about the column or
data store in BigQuery.
We're only accessing the
title, the views, the
Wikipedia project,
the language.
We're only accessing a subset of
the columns in this table,
so we're only hitting about
half of the data.
So 505 gigabytes, I think was
23.9 seconds or something like
that, and we can see here all
the page views of the pages
that matched that regular
expression.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This
is an amazing query
with a lot of value.
You can see that it's looking
at products, and you can see
which products have been more
viewed on Wikipedia.
There's some information
about health.
There's some disease here.
So you can actually look and see
what people are actually
searching for in a matter
of seconds, really.
RYAN BOYD: So we often use this
Wikipedia data set to
show off some of the power of
BigQuery, because it's a great
open data set, freely
available to access.
We actually downloaded all
of this data off of
dumps.wikimedia.org, but you
can see the analogy here,
probably, between this and some
of your business problems
that you may have.
So you think about views on
advertising and the click
throughs on your ads.
That can really add up as you
have your ads on hundreds of
millions of mobile devices
and web browsers.
That can really add up, and
this same type of query is
often used for things
like that.
So for instance, if the title of
the Wikipedia page here was
the ad campaign, and you could
figure out which ad campaign
got the most views when that ad
campaign was a particular
type, and maybe that type could
be a simple regular
expression or something
like that.
So these queries are really--
we're doing them in Wikipedia,
but you can think about your
own business challenges and what
types of queries you want
to be able to do.
But a terabyte of data
in 23.9 seconds?
It's not really a bad query
time here, especially with
being able to do regular
expressions on all the rows.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: In this
query, we had a simple sum
aggregate, so let's take a look
at some other aggregate
queries that are possible to
do with Google BigQuery.
So when I talk about aggregates,
I'm not just
talking about sums.
I'm talking about things like
counts and basic statistical
measures like standard
deviation, average, variance,
and things like that.
Like Ryan said, in a relational
database, sometimes
we try to solve the speed
problem with querying for
aggregates with indexes.
Of course, that's challenging
in itself.
With a document store, something
like CouchDB, you
could run aggregate queries,
but oftentimes you have to
write your own custom
MapReduce.
What's great about BigQuery
is it combines the
best of both worlds.
You can express these aggregate
queries in terms of
a SQL-style language.
So let's take a look some
of these examples.
This is a really interesting
query.
We're going to look at birth
weights by state-- so we'll
just pick Ohio in this case--
by a particular year, and we're
going to look at how
cigarette use of the mother
affects the birth weight
RYAN BOYD: And this is actually
a public data set
that you can play around with.
All of our public data sets,
many of the things that we're
talking about here, are
available in the public data
sets on BigQuery.
You can look in the
table of contents.
I think it says public data sets
or sample data sets, I
believe, and all these
are available.
Play around with them, and let
us know what interesting
queries that you come up with.
But let's show this
example here.
And if there's any of the things
that we're talking
about that aren't there yet, we
will work on coming up with
some other data as well.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This is a
good opportunity, too, to tell
you that you have a query quota
that's free, so you can
actually try this out for free,
and do some queries, and
learn how to use it without
billing turned on.
So let's check out this query.
Let's see if there is a
difference between mothers who
smoke and baby weight for
this particular year.
So wow.
That was a very fast query.
In just three seconds, we
returned this data.
It looks like we processed
about almost 3 and 1/2
gigabytes in just
three seconds.
And you can see when cigarette
use is true, it looks like the
baby weight is slightly
smaller.
It's actually quite a--
RYAN BOYD: Half a pound
difference.
We should warn we're not
statisticians here.
We're not defining a
causation, but just
correlation.
But a half a pound difference
when the mothers said that
they smoked cigarettes.
Now, not sure that those answers
are always accurate to
that question, but a half a
pound difference-- and we can
actually see here, the mother
age is different, too.
So it looks like the mothers
who are giving birth to
children who smoked cigarettes
are actually about two years
younger than the mothers who
said that they didn't smoke
cigarettes.
And I don't know if that has
anything to do with cigarette
use in general, or if that just
has to do with the ones
that would admit to smoking
cigarettes, but it's still an
interesting type of ad hoc
analysis that you could do
here, and especially with the
group buys, averages, standard
deviations.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Imagine
piping this data into a
statistics package to do a
little bit more analysis on
that as well.
It's very simple.
RYAN BOYD: We don't have this
prepared here today, but since
you brought up statistics
packages, oftentimes people
will take data out of BigQuery
and do like a
hash function on it.
And they can do that hash
function on it to select a
random sampling of their
data, then, to use in
a statistics package.
Most statistics packages won't
support if you have hundreds
of millions or billions of rows
of data, but you can use
that BigQuery hash function to
select your random subset.
Use hash, and then [? mob ?]
that by a particular number.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So let's
look at another example.
This is an example actually
that Ryan came up with.
It's an interesting use of
BigQuery to bucket birth by
sex and by state.
So what's great about
this is it uses
a conditional statement.
So if you can see
the statement--
we're selecting by state, and
we're saying if Ismail, which
is a Boolean, label that as a
male birth, otherwise female.
[INAUDIBLE]
do a count, [INAUDIBLE]
and group by state.
The other interesting thing is
we're using a function called
having, and having is a lot
like aware statement, but
we're using the aggregate data,
in this case the count,
to compare.
So this is a very fast query.
As you can see, some of the
more populous states, like
California, you can see how
many births were male, how
many were female.
And we're counting only states
with over, is it
five million births?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, over
five million births.
Well, only states that have
five million births of
children of the same sex.
So it looks like Texas had more
than five million births
of males but less births
of females.
But Texas and California,
apparently, are quite populous.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This
is really interesting.
So let's take a look at another
statistics query.
We're going to look at a
standard deviation query.
I was really interested to see
if there are any outliers, and
standard deviation is a great
way to look for outliers.
So what we want to do is figure
out what birth weights
are several times a standard
deviation higher than average,
and sort of get a baseline.
RYAN BOYD: So I'm just
trying to find
that query here quickly.
Let's see here--
there we go.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This query
is looking at the entire
natality data set.
This is a full table scan, and
we're finding the average plus
four times the standard
deviation away.
And here we go.
In just a few seconds,
we found that
it's about 12.7 pounds.
So that's several standard
deviations
away from the average.
Now we can take that value and
run a similar query, and find
if there are any outlying months
and states where babies
were a little bit heftier
than that.
RYAN BOYD: And Michael's going
to have to point out this
query for me here again.
There we go.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We're going
to take that value that
we got in the standard deviation
query and rerun it
on the entire data set,
and look for outliers.
Oh, look.
So it looks like Maryland in
1990 in December had 12 babies
that were very far above that
four times the standard
deviation away from
the average.
So I'm not sure exactly what's
going on there, but it's
interesting that that's a
slightly smaller state than
some of these other ones, like
New York and California, so it
looks like an outlier
case to me.
So you can use BigQuery to slam
through tons of data to
find cases like this with these
statistical queries.
And I just wanted to highlight
another query.
It's the--